Donald Trump's personal attorney Michael
Cohen reportedly hand-delivered a
so-called peace plan for Russia and
Ukraine
- now disgraced former national security
adviser Michael Flynn which included
here we go now
the removal of Russian sanctions a topic
we now know was discussed when Flynn
spoke to the Russian ambassador to the
United States prior to the inauguration
of Donald Trump Flynn lied about this
he has since resigned and in exchange
for lifting sanctions against Russia
this plan that Donald Trump had was
going to see Russia withdrawing support
from pro-russia separatists in Ukraine
and it also would have allowed Russia to
maintain control over Crimea pretty damn
good deal for Russia if you ask me and
of course Michael Cohen is denying the
entire thing he sent the series of text
messages yesterday to Business Insider
where he said he never delivered any
documents to Flynn or to any member of
the White House nor engage the president
about this issue he's saying essentially
not only did he not deliver the
documents he just wasn't involved in any
of this period the New York Times is
standing by its story telling The
Washington Post that Cohen told The
Times in no uncertain terms that he did
deliver the Ukraine proposal to Michael
Flint's office and also this has been
confirmed by Felix Sater felix aider or
cetera i don't know how he pronounces
his last name is a russian American real
estate developer who has helped Donald
Trump to look for deals to do in Russia
and he says yeah it was delivered by
Michael Cohen to Flynn's office so once
again Pat multiple sources multiple
sources on record is saying this is how
it happened and as as we're used to now
the Trump associate just flat-out denies
that anything took place at all who do
you believe at this point right I mean
it would be interesting to see if
Michael Flynn was the first person out
of many to start resigning from the
Trump administration with Michael Cohen
being next because Trump is willing to
throw them under the bus and he doesn't
treat his subordinates very well so I
mean this could be a trend we see yeah
Cohen of course not part of the
administration per se which is also what
makes this more to
during that he's Trump's sort of like
personal lawyer so obviously he's one of
the guys involved in being involved with
Trump regardless the buck stops with
Trump though absolutely and there's
another reason that this is huge
remember that Trump blackmail file
talked about it a bunch of times in that
file there were allegations that a
Michael Cohen went to Prague to meet
with Russian officials secretly he
denied it denied ever having been to
Prague and it was then thought you know
that it's possible that this referred to
a different Michael Cohen who went if we
go back through the file though it more
generally said that there was a man
named Michael Cohen that was part of an
ongoing secret liaison relationship
between the Trump campaign and Russian
leadership it may indeed be that it was
this Cowan that was being referred to
and it would be yet another data point
or an alleged data point at least that
suggests connections between Michael
Cohen and Russia it could be yet another
corroborated aspect of the Trump
blackmail file in addition to everything
that we learned about last week and
knowing what we know about Michael Cohen
Michael Flynn and Felix aider if this is
true what it means is that as part of
the incoming Trump administration a
trump organization lawyer was involved
in and hand-delivered a plan that he
wrote along with a Russian American
businessman that we know was formerly
linked to the Mafia to the President of
the United States is now disgraced lying
liar former national security adviser
who was forced to resign after he lied
about his contact with Russian
individuals and by the way the plan was
to remove sanctions on Russia nothing to
see here folks right Pat nothing here to
be concerned about yeah I think a lot of
people wonder what Russia would want in
exchange for influencing our elections
but I mean that's pretty clear to me a
favorable position on Crimea for example
reduction of sanctions would be a good
thing for them and also just this idea
that well we do things that are wrong
and America does things that are wrong
too and so it's both one in the same
last thought on this I want to suggest
an alternative way to think about the is
Trump a Russian puppet question if
Donald Trump were compromised by the
Russians this is exactly what it would
look like so
it's not proof that Trump is compromised
but if I said to you explain to me what
types of things would be going on if
indeed Donald Trump were compromised by
the Russians this is exactly what it
would look like and that's something I
think we shouldn't forget today's
episode of the David Pakman show is made
possible in part by Warby Parker
eyeglasses Warby Parker recently did the
right thing and ditched advertising on
right-wing conspiracy website Breitbart
pulling their ads off and you can get
the free five-day home Tryon from Warby
Parker check out their glasses I use
them when I'm not wearing contact lenses
I started with the free at-home trial
they send you five pairs of glasses you
see which ones you like you send them
back and whichever one you pick they
will put your prescription into I like
this because I can actually show the
glasses to other people and not have to
just decide on the spot like in an
eyeglass store the eyeglass industry is
controlled by very few corporations that
keep the prices very very high even over
$300 for prescription glasses with Warby
Parker they start at just 95 bucks mine
costs that including lenses and for
every pair sold they give a pair to
someone in need so to try the five pairs
and support the David Pakman show go to
Warby Parker trial comm /t DPS